Okay, this first set here represents a full-sibling
relationship; and the second set represents a parent-child relationship.
Now, why is this? Well, let's start with the
parental one. Remember that you receive a whole chromosome
from one parent, and a whole chromosome from another
parent. So if you compared your IBS score, the
SNV's on your chromosomes You should have a complete
matching set for the whole length of a chromosome.
But two siblings, on the other hand, didn't
receive the same kind of chromosome form each parent
because of what? Recombination during meiosis. So instead
they share segments of certain chromosomes with each other
from both parents. So in the chromosome they
got from dad, they'll share some segments. But remember,
dad's chromosomes recombine. And so it's not the same
for both children. The same thing with mom's chromosomes.
You'll notice that there's roughly 50% here in
the parental child relationship, sharing 50% of the
DNA. Right one whole chromosome set matches and
the other one doesn't. And even in the full
sibling case, you end up with roughly 50%. If we add up the shaded region it's
about 50%, in the unshaded regions that's also
50%. So even though you're half related To your
full parents and your full siblings. The half that's related is
different when we look at the order of the SNVs on the
chromosome. This king of analysis is the basis for something we'll learn
about in just a little bit, called identity by descent or IBD.